question des des des extraterrestres
évidemment c'est c'est dur de d'y
répondre par ou al c'est les
extraterrestres c'est pas les petits
hommes verts si tu veux mais la vie dans
l'espace on s'interdit pas de penser que
ça peut exister ailleurs sous forme
bactérienne sous forme tu vois il y a
pas de raison qu'on soit unique au monde
il y a des des exoplanètes il y en a des
milliers c'est pas des milliards donc
euh voilà et on et on va faire des
missions d'ailleurs sur Europa qui est
une lune de Jupiter pour justement on
sait qu'il y a de l'eau il y a une
couche de glace il y a de l'eau en
dessous on a vu des gzer d'eau bon on
pense qu'il y a peut-être des trucs à
trouver ouais ça peutêtre des choses
assez assez fascinantes à à voir oua un
peu loin pour envoyer desémissions
habite pas